Throughout the "Halloween" franchise, the timeline
diverges multiple times, and the main series even
features one entry without Michael Myers.
But we're here to help sort through it all,
so grab your favorite carving knife and let's dig
in. This is Michael Myers' backstory explained.
The story of Michael Myers begins on Halloween
night in 1963 in the suburban town of Haddonfield,
Illinois, as six-year-old Michael
gets up, walks into his sister's room,
and stabs her to death. Michael is sent to
Smith's Grove Sanitarium, where he spends
the rest of his childhood and adolescence.
He is observed and studied by Dr. Sam Loomis,
who winds up becoming an expert on the man,
the myth, the legend that is Michael Myers.
On October 30, 1978, the story of Michael
Myers begins in earnest. He escapes from
Smith's Grove the night before Halloween
and descends upon Haddonfield. Meanwhile,
high schooler Laurie Strode, played by Jamie Lee
Curtis in her first film role, is preparing for
a boring Halloween night babysitting young Tommy
Doyle near the Myers home, which is now abandoned.
Instead of having a dull night earning a little
money on the side, Laurie ends up at the tail
end of Michael's killing spree. After a
night of tracking Michael, Loomis comes
to the house where Laurie is fighting him off
and manages to put six bullets in the killer.
“Halloween II [“two”] picks up later that night,
when Laurie is brought to the Haddonfield Memorial
Hospital, where Michael reappears to finish what
he started. The sequel begins what would become a
major expansion of the "Halloween" lore, by
revealing that Laurie is Michael's sister.
"That girl, that Strode girl.
That's Michael Myers' sister."
According to "Halloween II," Laurie was extremely
young when Michael killed the rest of his family.
As a result, she doesn't remember her real family,
and was taken in and raised by the Strodes.
This explains why Michael is so dead set on
killing Laurie, as he wants to finish what
he started. "Halloween II" ends with Michael being
presumed dead when there's a fire at the hospital.
The third movie in the franchise, "Halloween
III: Season of the Witch," was an experiment
that tried to take the franchise in an anthology
direction, and away from Michael Myers. After
lukewarm reviews, the series fell into limbo for
years. After it returned with 1988's "Halloween 4:
The Return of Michael Myers," it never again
strayed from the unfeeling killer at its core.
"Halloween 4" stars Danielle Harris as
Jamie Lloyd, Laurie Strode's daughter.
Jamie is living with a foster family and has
recurring dreams of Michael coming to get her.
Those dreams turn out to be warnings when Michael
wakes up from a 10-year coma and goes after his
closest living relative. The movie ends in a
standoff near an abandoned mine, but only after
depicting a moment of psychic connection initially
established via physical contact with Jamie.
In the final moments of "Halloween
4," the family returns home--
Jamie eerily wearing a similar costume to the one
Michael wore all the way back in 1963. Just when
everyone thinks they’re safe, Jamie attacks
her foster mother and reappears at the top
of the stairs holding a bloody pair of scissors.
Dr. Loomis tries to shoot her, but is thwarted.
As "Halloween 5: The Revenge of Michael
Myers" begins, Jamie is mute and in a
psychiatric hospital after attempting to kill
her foster mother. This is implied to be the
result of a moment she shared with Michael
in the previous movie, sparking a connection
that leaves Jamie suffering hallucinations that
keep her bond with Michael shrouded in mystery.
In "The Curse of Michael Myers," Michael
returns to his childhood home to kill the
Strode family that now lives there. Tommy Doyle,
now an adult, still lives across the street.
"My name's Tommy. I was only
8 years old when I saw him."
Doyle has been studying Michael and has
discovered that the root of his evil is an
ancient Druid curse known as "Thorn." This
brings the family connection full circle,
as the conditions of the curse say the afflicted
must kill their next of kin on Halloween night.
Made 20 years after the original, "Halloween H20:
20 Years Later" brought Jamie Lee Curtis back for
a story pitched as a direct sequel to "Halloween
II." This movie returns Michael's motivations
to their roots, with him specifically
trying to find and kill Laurie Strode.
"H20" brings Michael from Haddonfield to
California, where Laurie has built a new
identity and life for herself as a schoolteacher.
However, he's foiled again with what looks like
the most definitive Michael kill yet, when
Laurie chops his head off with a fire axe.
In an unexpected turn, "Halloween: Resurrection"
reveals that the ending of "H20" was an illusion.
Of course the decapitated man wasn't Michael.
Instead, Laurie killed an innocent man,
and now has been institutionalized.
"I knew you'd come for me, sooner or later."
Despite Laurie's best-laid traps, Michael breaks
into the sanitarium where she's being held.
She's about to kill him, but begins to grapple
with his mask to make sure it's the real Michael.
That doubt gives Michael enough time to stab and
finally kill Laurie, tossing her off the roof.
And that’s only the beginning of Resurrection--
Michael goes on yet another killing spree,
aided in part by Busta Rhymes and
Tyra Banks. Yes, you heard that right.
Laurie's death could have been a
huge moment in the "Halloween" canon,
but it finally left the franchise
nowhere to go but back to the beginning.
In 2007, the franchise returned thanks
to Rob Zombie, who directed a remake of
the original 1978 Carpenter classic. This
poorly received installment more or less
retold the story of the first movie, but many
felt it didn't hold a candle to the original.
Zombie followed up his remake with his own
version of "Halloween II." Set two years
after the events in Haddonfield, Laurie begins
having hallucinations in which she sees herself
acting out Michael's past murders. The movie
also reveals Laurie to be Michael's sister,
Angel Myers, only at the end of this film, Laurie
manages to actually kill Michael. After stabbing
him with his own knife, Laurie puts on his
mask and becomes the new "Michael Myers."
With the 2018 reimagining of
"Halloween," the series went
back to basics, giving viewers a
direct sequel to 1978's "Halloween"
and disregarding the big twist connecting
Laurie and Michael in "Halloween II."
In this timeline, Michael has been
incarcerated for the past 40 years
for the killings he committed in the very
first movie. He breaks out to track down
and kill Laurie, who in this continuity is
definitely not his sister. Over the years,
Laurie has become a reclusive alcoholic who's very
good at setting traps for Michael. It pays off,
because a trap she lays for him sets her house
ablaze, with Michael presumably dead inside. But
with sequels "Halloween Kills" and "Halloween
Ends" announced shortly after that movie's
release, it was soon clear that Michael also
survived that fire, and lived to kill again.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.